SPEAKER 1: What was in the
mind of Winston Churchill?
Why did he think that he
could afford not to negotiate?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In terms of supreme command,
the Allies were very lucky.
Because had the war broken out
when Stanley Baldwin was Prime
Minister, I think Britain would
have not done very well at all.
It broke out when Neville
Chamberlain was prime minister.
But quickly, he
began to bring people
in the cabinet who advised
him, corrected him,
educated him about
what was going on.
He still felt that there was
some chance of a negotiated
peace after the fall of France.
But on May 10, 1940, the day
that Germany invaded France,
there was a radical
change of government.
Winston Churchill
came in, and Churchill
was determined to not
surrender, not negotiate,
but not only fight the
Germans and the Italians,
but defeat them.
Now, this was a
very strange idea
because, within three weeks,
there would just be Britain,
and there would be all
of occupied Europe.
So what was in the mind
of Winston Churchill?
Why did he think that he
could afford not to negotiate?
Hitler had offered him
a deal where he said,
we will not invade
or bomb you, and we
will let you have your empire.
Just call off the war.
And then Hitler thought that he
would turn his attention then
without a worry over either
Britain or the United States,
and he could turn his
attention to the Soviet Union.
But Churchill was
not just a romantic.
He was a very brilliant
guy who was convinced
that the last minute armament
of the Royal Air Force,
and given the fact that the
Royal Navy was the largest
navy in the world, meant
everybody took a deep breath.
They said to themselves, for all
of Germans' continental ground
power, land forces, they
cannot get across the channel
because the British
Navy will sink it,
sink ships from the German Navy.
And they do not have the ability
to achieve air superiority
over Britain.
And, therefore, they
can't attack us.
And Churchill said,
well, you know what?
We can't invade either.
So there's going
to be a standoff.
And that standoff is going to
favor us, because eventually,
authoritarians like Hitler and
Stalin cannot trust each other.
They'll have a falling out.
And at some point, they
will fight each other,
and that will be
to our advantage.
And at some point, we understand
that either the Japanese
or the Germans or the Italians
will do something stupid
and draw the United
States into the war.
Churchill was already
envisioning an alliance
that was to happen a year and
a half later of the Soviet
Union, the United States,
and the British empire
against the Axis triad.
And they would have
enormous advantages
in terms of
manpower, population,
industrial strength,
and geography.
And that's exactly
what happened.
In America, it's hard to think
how we would have been prepared
for Pearl Harbor without
Franklin Roosevelt. By that, I
mean the Republican Party
was primarily isolationist.
And the Democratic
Party was focused
on the Great Depression.
And so, at this time,
people were saying,
we cannot invest in military
expenses and armies and navies
and air forces.
FDR, along with a brilliant
congressman, Carl Vinson,
thought otherwise.
And FDR understood that wherever
we were going to fight, Pacific
or European theaters,
we needed a navy
to transport soldiers over
there and to protect them
from coming over here.
So in a series of Naval Acts, in
the late 1930s, the Carl Vinson
Naval Act 1, 2, 3, and et
cetera, we had on the books
a new Pacific fleet,
about five times larger
than was at Pearl
Harbor, and much better,
characterized by Baltimore
heavy cruisers, Essex carriers,
the Iowa-class battleships.
That was already on the books.
It was already budgeted before
we went in to World War II.
And FDR, in sometimes cagey,
Machiavellian fashion,
was reassuring an
isolationist nation in 1940
that it would not go to war,
even though he was taking
quite dramatic steps to
prepare it to go to war
and might even welcome
it going to war.
And the Second World War was
ultimately a story of people,
how people died, and how people
made decisions that determined
which side won or lost.
I think we can sum
it up by the results,
because the proof of the
pudding is always in the eating.
And when you look at this
vast canvas of death that
was the Second World
War, 65 million people,
and we have to
ask ourselves, why
were they able to be so
successful in the war?
And I think the answer
is the United States
and the British had an
overarching principle
that they were going to
find ways to win the war
and to wage it with the
least possible injury
to their own
country's populations.
And that was completely
diametrically opposed
to the Axis powers'
war of aggression
where they thought that
we're super people.
We're going to
destroy inferiors,
and if we lose people,
it's a glorious thing
to die during a war.
Or in the Soviet Union's
idea that all that matters is
survival of the Soviet state.
Millions do not matter
if the Soviet principal,
the Soviet project survives.
Ultimately, then,
the story of people
turns out to be the brilliance
of Winston Churchill
and Franklin Roosevelt, and
leading the democracies, not
just to war, but
to a victorious war
and at very little
cost in comparison
to the other belligerents.
SPEAKER 2: Thank
you for watching.
We hope you're enjoying
our Highlight series
and invite you to explore our
complete course on the Second
World Wars.
All of Hillsdale
College's online courses
are free and for everyone
who loves to learn.